we're starting to step aside off in
Houston because we just finished a PI
episode and we were feeling a little bit
of a late night snack today I'm worth it
we're gonna be trying three different
buzz and three drastically different
price points to find out which one is
the most worth it at his price and
joining us on our adventure today is a
very fun guy by the name of Justin you
owner of Theodore Rex
he's a local from Houston James Beard
Award winner certainly knows his [ __ ] he
likes to grab a bull after a hard day of
work and that's what we're gonna do with
him show us how it happens
late night style in Houston Wow it is
midnight right now nuh-uh
don't stop when we walk in Ke$ha we're
that you just turn into a bun yeah my
name is Kevin Pham I am the proprietor
here at father by night we do authentic
from 4 p.m. till 12 a.m. and Friday and
Saturdays you open to 3 a.m.
oh really where did you learn to make
pot I've always wanted to learn it it
was like a secret held away from me like
mom telling you to close your eyes when
there's a naked woman on TV my
grandfather who from Vietnam because
he's retired there and I showed up every
day just to learn in my stead that would
come over and show me his way confusing
at first but then I got the gist of it
develop my own well the thing about fuzz
everyone has their own preference I like
to eat bone marrow and we never had in
our formula and one day I just like hey
this looks pretty good you know and I
gave it to a friend my friend actually
was sitting with Allison cook of the
Houston Chronicle a weak layer were in
the Houston Chronicle for a bone marrow
didn't which we never sold and that kind
of boosted us the first year and we
walked in and especially me mentally
here I was your wife
Yeah right she's the great if it weren't
for her that I just could not laugh or I
wouldn't last year by myself why is that
the way we operate has always
Mon Paul no how do you make your bra
well it starts with the bones the
centerpiece and the joints so it really
is bone see and brisket when you look at
barbecue pitmasters they're called
pitmasters what we do is similar through
being called a pot master you know that
flame has to be low simmer you know and
cook the noodles first strain it out top
off the meats and then you just were
onions pot Master thing I've never heard
pot master I kind of yeah good I think
after this you're gonna be pot master
for sure all right one last thing okay
Steven I noticed you have this thing
going on here it's absolutely uh
pickled lemons to make that movie Oh
pickled lemonade we are here with chef
Justin you you had this drink before I
have theirs all right here's the nice
Bopha oh yeah that is amazing this is
kind of a dead ringer for Gatorade
yeah and I guess there's a good amount
of salt in Gatorade - we were some fun I
mean Andrew kind of like you know in
high school cheated off your exam and we
got your order we've got it so it's
actually funny because I cheated off as
somebody else's order it's called an M
gone [ __ ] out is the fatty brisket and
then Gunn is attended to me it has all
like the perfect little bits the reason
why I love it here is that they cut it
almost perfect size every time so to me
you sip the broth first that's like the
ringer for like a really great fun this
one's like it's such a clean broth
they've obviously taken a lot of time to
like blanch the bones or skim the bones
it's like a meal and a glass of water in
one bite cuz I'm both getting the the
savory bits but I feel refreshed right
how's that broth for you Andrew oh it's
that right there the fatty brisket that
fat hanging out that's another level of
flavor so for you is this broth perfect
right now or you gonna drop it
absolutely perfect you're not gonna like
add anything I love a good amount of
cilantro I like to have it with the
stems too really all about that texture
break it up so it's a bite-sized Thai
basil some bean sprouts I like my bean
sprouts are off you got the bone marrow
and then
add it to like a little section that I'm
about to eat it's just like so it's good
like you'll get like this punch of
richness maybe it's cuz you know it's
late at night it's made a new friend but
this may be like my favorite food right
now in the world like I love sushi I
love what I love I don't want to say
acai bowls for this kind of but I do
love a bowl a little bit of shame in
there but this is really hitting the
spot for me right now all right
it is so late I've been hooked us up
with another specialty drink artichoke
tea artichoke tea I'm not a refreshing
thing another one so we are leaving bub
in by night we're actually leaving by
car and so is Justin he actually is
heading off to his restaurant to clean
up now yeah so our next stop is actually
in Hope look at that so we just had some
amazing fun he's to learn a lot from
Justin and now we've come to Honolulu
and we're gonna be trying some delicious
spa from a place called the pig and the
lady three types of fun
we're eatin delicious soup that's the
soup from which all life comes I'm
Andrew I'm the chef/owner of the pig and
Lady restaurant gonna be giving you guys
are far broth we're gonna do three
different versions one of them is the
pop pop which is a northern style FIFA
we also do seasonal brats one of them is
the depth off we also have a vegan
option which we're really proud of could
you tell us a little bit about the
naming of the pig in the waiting I'm the
pig I'm born in the year of the pig and
the lady is my mother and also like
represents my wife my best friend it was
just a way to honor them the FIFA which
should be having first its Baba so it's
a northern style pretty much the heart
and soul of the restaurant that's mom's
recipe we don't mess with that fresh
rice noodles I'm gonna rice noodle and
they just make everything by hand it
just has a really nice texture we get
our beef from uh kweli
ransom kawaii typically we use brown
which is the Psalter part it's a leaner
type of beef play is very tender
I've never had felt like this before
I've always had it where you have the
vegetable
side but here it's all done for you and
this is what I'm talking about this
drink is called Cobra Commander be
sharing yeah Oh spicy cutest thing I've
ever seen oh oh yeah Cheers sliced beef
wow that's so tender yeah that's so good
Adam you should try the beef right now
while it's still a little bit raw you go
Wow
Adam just gave the why'd I look broth
I'm broth boys I'm into that okay
there's put my straw yeah go for it
no I'm not I'm not an animal this is
like a baptism for my mouth so you have
been born again in the name of Thoth
my mouth is one of them is the Dafa we
get married sucks we go ahead and poach
that we'll slice up the medium-rare
poached duck breast and it will put the
bones back in and then cook that for a
further eight hours that allows us all
the duck penis to come out and then fat
renders out from the broth and we'll
save all of that duck fat to finish the
broth we also put the poached egg yolk
it's you know kind of affordable luxury
that everybody loves yolk time oh yes
I'm gonna duck my duck with a ducky yolk
they're just word that they use in
Malaysia touch a lot and it means when
something is so rich that the more you
eat it you get sick of it and this is
the anti July I want to drink this Olfa
and then I want to eat another bowl for
tomorrow for breakfast for lunch for
dinner and just for the rest of my life
I just want to spray this broth on
myself like kawaman we also have a vegan
flood that we're featuring it's a
challenge in itself to emulate the same
experience that you would have with a
rich duck broth or rich beef broth the
broth is made with a vegetable and kombu
to give it depth enoki mushroom for
meatiness or oil from Thai basil add a
little bit more lusciousness see the
broth that was a kind of our pet project
and
the end result of that were really stone
this is the one I'm most intrigued by
look how pretty this is
yeah that's what I want my garden to
look like when I get older yeah
soup garden drizzle sizzle all right a
little bit of tomato it's a wonderful oh
my it's extremely delicious but I've
never had a tomato in this setting
before I'm just delighted Adams gone
rogue chef Andrew said that this would
be as satisfying as the other pleasant
he's absolutely right like it's not so
different like suspicious he's cheating
like that great for what you were a
vegan fiend and now we got some shave
ice what flavors you do get on top I got
a bad assembly I kind of got peas snow
colors coffee liliquoi passion and creme
brulee I don't think I'm doing it right
I got the strawberry the guava and the
mango and that's how you do it
look at this does it get better than
this sunset ocean breeze icy refreshment
we went from a port to an island and now
we head to Las Vegas and specifically
we're in Chinatown we're headed to our
last location but before we go there I
have a perfect in Seattle they have a
challenge for fall where you would need
an entire massive bowl of pho in 90
minutes you win $100
in that bowl of pho is four liters of
broth four liters
you cannot consume that much liquid in
one sitting
that's too much I can't believe how far
we've come to make this video it's right
wisten Honolulu to Las Vegas but you
know what I like about that there's good
fun all over America people are doing
big things all over the country yeah
next time we'll just have to actually go
to Vietnam done I'm anemic I flew and
I'm the owner District one kitchen and
bar here in Las Vegas Nevada
what does that name come from come from
District one in Ho Chi Minh City and
that's where I born and raised it have
all kind of different foods people go
there you know for entertainment dining
today I'll be serving you guy I love
tougher without men laughter life for me
when the last to get here we boil them
first and then I'll take the shell I
make a concentrate lobster bait and we
use the head we flash fry them and we
cook it in the broth so I bring out more
lobster flavor and then I'll marry dad
with the bone broth from the original
fur that we cooked here with Ock tell
the people so you have a really good
grasp on the bone and the lobster flavor
and do we get other items on the side or
usually what people hold it a lot
further they have like two three people
so sometimes people want stuff in Turk
we serve with the fat of bone marrow and
we call it the big bone soup in the bone
marrow that were you to cook the foie
gras with Barnea so baby look at that
you know when Godzilla emerges from the
sea oh yes and he's like coming up to
the city to destroy it and his head just
pops out of the water
that's what this is like all right broth
first CP brah juice I'm surprised at how
much you can taste a lobster oh yeah
let me makes me hungrier than seeing a
whole lobster dinner alive that's the
good thing about lobster you don't like
you're gonna pay this much for a lobster
I don't want you to sauce up my lobster
much give me the pure case of lobster
it's like a steak I'm gonna make the
perfect little Bowl got the lobster
broth get a little bit of this bone
marrow a little bit of noodle this is
only eight your zest there you go it's
just a touch when a soup makes it go
after taking a big slurp of it no me
bone me is like if I was a Bond villain
and you were my henchman
your name would be the bone me no okay
if you were a Marvel superhero your name
would be bone me yes that's right and
that would be brought boy let's go fight
crime born in a brothel no no no no no
we just had a bowl of pho with a lobster
in it like literally a lobster flew in
from Maine lobster flew in all right I'm
tired
so Andrew which spa was the most worth
to you you ready for this
I bet can't guess what I'm gonna say I
know you're gonna say thinking the lady
is my worth a winner
what no it was the best single slurp of
broth I've ever had how are the winner
goes to club in by nights wow I did not
see that coming really yeah and you know
what that night I dreamed about the
fatty brisket what's your word the
winner
dad I'm plating in the lady coming it's
like a cow no Lobster went in a hot tub
together
then I got to heat it that could have
went weird and I'm glad he didn't oh
there it went weird in the best way
possible oh oh yes